hi there mr piggy hello
i appreciate you talking to me
and in this movie you get to host a
halloween party where you're dressed up
as kermit and kermit is dressed up as
you
what did you think of your kermit
costume how did it feel to wear it did
it give you any new understanding of
kermit
yeah no it's
it was a good costume it was a good
costume i mean
i think i look better as him
than he looks as moi
um
but i you know i i much prefer just
being me
just dressing the way i normally dress
you know you can't really call
uh
kermit's you know
the kermit costume i wore you know
fabulous or anything because
you know it's just
you know
it's just kermit
but
um it was fun it was fun
you make it fabulous thank you
did you get to give any input into the
miss piggy costume that kermit got to
wear
oh yeah sure yeah i mean um
he's got a boa it's actually one of my
boas
and um
you know but i i didn't let him wear my
pearls nobody
wears the pearls they don't touch them
for anyone in the world who's thinking
of dressing up as miss piggy for
halloween what advice would you give
them when it comes to capturing the
perfect miss piggy pizzazz
the perfect miss piggy pizzazz i like
that
um
well sure
there are the the um
the accessories the pearls the gloves
the boas
you know the hair the hair
um
but
it's really about striking an attitude
you know
you know being being strong
and uh
you know not letting anybody
push you around
yeah
and of course being fabulous
well you also got to be madame leota in
this how did you feel about seeing
yourself as a floating head in a crystal
ball
you know honestly
uh i wasn't really thrilled about it at
first i mean you know
sticking your head in a fishbowl
for you know a couple hours of shooting
not exactly fun
not my idea of fun no
but
you know when i saw the finished product
i thought oh my goodness gracious
look how much i did
with so little
i mean they say um you know an actor
you know the best actors they're they're
all about the face
well
i hit a home run in this one sweetheart
oh my goodness
i don't know i think i think maybe
i'm not gonna i'm just gonna be like i'm
just gonna be ahead in everything i do
like all my future movies this is gonna
be my head
i might even limit it to you know just
just above
just the eyes
i think i think i can really do it all
just with those
what do you think
i think they should definitely pay you
extra for the rest of the
the body
that's a good idea
you want to be my agent
that's really that's a really clever
idea
well you're a diva you're a fashion icon
you're a film and tv star what is left
that you haven't done yet is there
anything you'd still like to conquer
um
studio exec
maybe
then i could green light all my own
movies
that's definitely a plan yeah
well i very much appreciate you giving
me your time this piggy thank you so
much for talking to me the muppets
haunted mansion
disney plus
absolutely thank you so much i'll be
watching it again and again